luca oder sie kisten du bist klug hallo
mein name ist luca und mein name war
auch vor zweieinhalb jahren schon luca
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht ich schaue
mir heute mal ein video von mir von vor
zweieinhalb jahren an
das wird peinlich das ist ein hunger
games video und zwar ja ich war noch nie
gut in hanna game lodge existiert ein
spaß witzig luca das erste mal mit face
cam am start
das war wirklich das erste mal dass sich
fans kann benutzer perfekt geht los die
atom kopf nicht da das ist so klumpp ich
wisse dann seht ihr mich nicht an
gemeinde kann diesen job wohl kaputt so
interessante sachen erzählen uns noch
mehr diese face cam ist halt einfach
auch übels riesig die ist einfach viel
zu groß sie verdeckt einfach das halbe
bild ja ja ja ok luca und cooler fresse
weshalb immer so ein wurm oder fresse
was redet der guck mir ganz viele hatten
haben das damals ich leute angeschaut
gut kennen kameraden 600d oder wartet
ist sich eher als wenn wir die kamera
doch klasse luca du bist auf jeden fall
sogar informiert
du bewegst dich nicht das stop ich doch
einfach mal die aufnahme mittendrin
das problem ist aber immer noch bei
canon wenn du einfach so sitzt und dumas
im frage antwort video du bewegst nicht
anstatt sie einfach nach zwei minuten
siebels die aufnahme wurde automatisch
passiert nobody knows what kämen sondern
weil ich würde ich trotzdem der cgfp es
und ich hörte den junge marie de kennt
es nicht man allerdings luca wie das
willst du sie wieder beginnen könnten
wenn die pädagogik habt dann wisst ihr
was das bedeutet auch ein pädagogischer
erst gerade gesagt ich hatte einfach die
pädagogik kommen sogar lauf lauf nein
nein nein du wirst nicht verlieren ich
glaube nicht ich glaube nicht laufen
oder gegen seinem fand gehen ja das ist
natürlich jetzt total optimal nein luca
zwei herzen zwei herzen bleiben scheint
es allerdings
du schaffst es luca luka kom kom kom
zwei herzen compo verdammt es ist alles
klar
habt ihr gesehen was da unten im chat
dann koche auch mit ganz normalem wasser
ich verstehe nicht warum werde ich jetzt
als star angesehen
stehen wir nicht so bekommt eine auf dem
server und alle denken nicht so ganz
normale menschen ohne mikros auch gar
nicht über steuern oder so ist dann
allerdings wieder die sache dass ich da
nicht ob ich wirklich aufnehmen oder ob
dann wieder sagt hey du bewegst dich zu
das komplette video besteht daraus dass
ich darüber rede dass menschen den
bildschirm neben der kamera guckt nicht
in die kamera selbst tut luca ball dann
ist man schneller aber kann einfach
doppel werde rücken
luka odak ist du bist klug die
verschiedene gemeinde warum ein hektar
bietet weil was machten dann noch spaß
ja das ist echt sowie so bietet man das
macht überhaupt keinen sinn beispiel
macht sich damit alles kaputt roman
gordon schwert okay ich glaube direkt
auf einen zu der einfachen holzschwert
hat jetzt laufe ich weiter zurück und
das einzige was ich habe sind einfach so
ein stückchen muss hier irgendwie weg
und überleben gute idee luca dass die
beste taktik in der pvp spielt das ist
einfach so der sinn des lebens einmal
weglaufen und überleben leben und leben
lassen
luca du bist so klug ohne spaß
geht man da luca gute idee gute idee
kommt luca com kommt boxen ich glaube an
dich du schaffst das
da läuft dagegen die kinder gute idee
lueg ag auf den typen darauf mit der
kompletten rüstung alles klar super idee
ja du bist so klug stefan forster so
kehlmann tc ist doch klar kannst du es
überhaupt keine ahnung von minecraft
also ja ja kann sein glaube an mich luca
die einfach drauf töte ihn das ist das
kann ich schwer sein eine mauer die
schalter glaub mir ich glaub an mich
hier raus geschafft hast ja ist das
fleisch jetzt ja angriff angriff luca
war cool werde so nice nice nice nice
keystone ok und hinter mir jetzt
wahrscheinlich institut mit dem schwert
oder lokal auf ich schaffe das nicht
mehr luca du musst dass du schaffst das
ich glaub an dich dort ganz toll an dich
heute hat selber keinen zorn deswegen
habt ihr wahrscheinlich gerade auch kein
ton luca du kombiniert wieder du bist
das es unfassbar wie oft uns das auch
einfach schon gesagt dass wir haben es
noch nicht verstanden letzte vielleicht
noch mal warum die keinen ton haben
beste voraussetzungen halbes herz und
zwei hoch weil viele leute ich glaube
ich bin jetzt einfach vom berg runter
das doch langweilig ein screenshot
machen an den das auch schön da ist er
gescheitert und das dorf das eigentlich
auch voll cool die hab ich denn jetzt
die fenster ausgeblendet
so was geht sagt er die kamera hält
zwischendurch einfach mal so auf zu
filmen
rom luca war cooler spruch lippischer
sprung ich bin tot gut erkannt schützt
euch gefallen hat daumen hoch geben wenn
es euch nicht gefallen einfach auch
enorm hoch heben das beste taktik könnte
auch in die kommentare schreiben was
eventuell noch so sehen wollt an
projekten und ob irgendwelche
verbesserungen habt bezüglich fans kämen
um ein foul
wieso ist das video sich endlich mal
vorbei luca ich habe früh recht nur
scheiße hochgeladen ja freuen ich weiß
nicht wie wir euch das jetzt gefallen
hat dass ich mir einfach ein anderes
video angeschaut haben viele gesagt
machen das doch mal schauen wie man als
video haben reagiert da so ein bisschen
drauf findet ihr das jetzt cool wenn es
euch gefallen da würde ich mich auf
jeden fall über eine positive bewertung
freuen wenn ich das noch mal machen soll
schreibt seine kommentare schreibt mir
videos in die kommentare
vielleicht soll ich das ja auch mal bei
anderen youtuber machen dass ich mir
andere videos anschauen darauf reagiere
und sonst sehen wir uns in einem
nächsten video wieder darauf